I know we only still sort of the house
were absolutely in favor of character
education,
but I am slightly worried at the moment
of some of the some of the noise I'm
hearing about perhaps grading character
or assessing character and using
character education as the means of
assessing pupils and most are absolutely
in favor of teaching character.
The measurement of parents when it's in
its infancy and one of the main
researchers in this field,
Angela Duckworth has said that such
measurements are not ready for any
serious kind of high stakes to use.
If we did end up grading pupils on
character and using such great for
anything significant,
that I guarantee you that it will become
effectively another middle class ramp
away for the underachieving children of
middle class professionals to gain the
system in their favor.
If we get rid of tests,
we will inevitably end up depending more
on assessment which disadvantages the
already disadvantaged and reinforces
prevailing stereotypes.
Now,
in the not too recent past,
these patterns were much better
understood than they are today.
In the 19th century,
the civil service reform was Charles
Northcote and Stafford Trevelyan.
For so long battle to make entry to the
Civil Service based on merit rather than
family connections in the early 20th
century.
Pioneering Labor education is such as
our external who trusts you mentioned
and Beatrice and Sydney web for an
education system based around exams.
Rh Tony didn't just believe as truth
remotely said in the amounts of Patriot
power of education.
He believed in the emancipator he power
of exams because he thought the only
exams could ensure that underprivileged
children were treated fairly.
Only exams could counter entrenched
privilege.
Very little has changed since then.
If anything,
we have more research to back up.
Tony's.
You,
uh,
exams are still the Ferris means of
assessment.
And if you care about meritocracy,
social mobility and fairness,
then you must be in favor of them.